ladies and gentlemen bevor es mit dem
video losgeht okay so kriege ich eure
aufmerksamkeit nicht so besser bevor es
mit dem video losgeht hier ein kleiner
disclaimer alkohol ist eine droge und
sie sollte auch so behandelt werden
bitte in maßen genießen bitte nicht
alleine genießen sondern in gesellschaft
und wenn ihr alt genug dafür seid könnt
eure grenzen und achtet auf eure
gesundheit jetzt geht's los ich fordere
dich heraus auch alleine und trank zu
malen
das video mit den meisten likes hat
geworden leute also eigentlich mein
video mit ich wurde herausgefordert mal
wieder von einer gewissen kelly misses
wie lok es begab sich vor zwei wochen
dann lud diese feine dame ein drunk art
school hoch ohne mich ohne mich und da
muss ich sagen challenge accepted kelly
challenge accepted die gute kelly cam
ist hat ein bild gemalt und zwar von
caspar david friedrich dem star der
deutschen romantik es heißt der wanderer
über dem nebelmeer und ich hab schon
wieder vergessen ich den satz angefangen
habe das ist das erste mal dass ich
einen drang auf meinem kanal hoch lade
ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt weil ich
tatsächlich glaube ich noch nie auf
diesem kanal trank war ich trink halt
immer aber es ist leider auch er so fade
mäßig weil ich halt ein cocktail trinken
und dann ist gut an ec2 von amazon
trinkspiele gefällt mir gerade ein okay
das zweite mal und damit würde ich sagen
hey leute hier sind eure mal wandern
willkommen zu ich rette kellys wanderer
über dem nebelmeer selbstporträt öl auf
leinwand
ja ok da war erst später angefangen zu
trinken
wir beginnen mit der grundierung des
bildes und dem fundament dieses formats
so erst mal hier mal ein bisschen über
die grundierung von kelly lästern kelly
hat das hier gekauft seit gestern dachte
ich okay dann werde ich meine leinwand
auch vorbereiten dann habe ich aber auf
dieser flasche gelesen dass man das 24
stunden vorher machen sollen und nicht
mit ölen mission soll das heißt wenn ich
das jetzt drauf machen dann wird sich
das so komisch mischen und es wird nicht
schön aus sie hat aber brother wähnt
unserem
er sagt aber glaube ich nehme mir auch
nicht ganz sicher mit ölfarbe grundieren
mit weißer natürlich habe ich mich auch
nicht lumpen lassen und eine neue
packung öl farben gekauft dann kann sie
mich von der steuer absetzen
ich habe ein bisschen angst vor dem
getrunken werden teil also wir haben
schon so ein bisschen unserem bier
genügt aber betrunken bin ich halt noch
lange mit aber keine sorge ich habe hier
eine studierte sozialpädagogik eine neue
staffel eingekauft okay jetzt mal so in
das weiß rein hier papa papa und wir
bereiten mal die leicht falsche pinsel
dafür ihr nehmt den hier
das wird jahre dauern die vorzubereiten
oh mein gott es schon geflogen wo ist
denn geflogen
eine gute idee es dauert hier noch
überflügeln und nicht schwanger saufen
was sagt denn die uhrzeit 20 7 einmal im
test mit der taschenlampe ist wenn ich
mir die geschichte farbe die leinwand
ist jetzt grundiert ich gehe kurz tanken
und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder was
meinen sie wie lange wir zum tanken
brauchen stimmt und es geht los mit dem
tanken denn 3 2 1
[Musik]
es ist jetzt genau 22 jahren einfach aus
wie jemand der so beim gericht die leute
bezeichnet weil die fotografierten
meinst du dich wenn du mich mal während
ich male das werde ich tun wenn ich weiß
wo man die künstlerischen fähigkeiten so
anni kelly auch an dich brust und let's
go sehr lecker
was passiert mit mir
was ist was here now you bietet devil
oder wird ja nun ein finale form
erreicht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
von technik unser hintergrund ist
natürlich jetzt nicht getrocknet das ist
jetzt mit aber immer noch versuchen
normales video draus zu machen hey leute
ich jetzt wieder euro pop rock und jetzt
mal ein paar happy tree friends zu den
heavy trash und rektor happy tree
friends alter mann abholen so laut
gerade ich habe jetzt werden immer
besser
dem alkohol dem so ein fahrer alkohol
wie zb farbe drauf da aber keinen druck
mehr nehmen ganz bisschen somit der
spitze des pinsel und das ist schon viel
zu viel kein wunder dass bei candy auch
so krank
ich fange jetzt einfach an okay wir sind
bob ross und ich bin reingegangen wird
haben wir durch schlamm
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die welt kommuniziert die bergearbeiten
berge machen wir mit brass technik so
hier haben eine gute farbe das ist eine
gute berg farbe remixen together like
this
[Musik]
nur der hintergrund des echten penalty
es wolken ja ich mache man die stellen
was hat der gemacht um so wollten hinten
sind ob er in bern ciena allgemeines dem
braunenberg auf dem er steht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kurzen besprechung pause haben uns
überlegt wie können wir das ganze ein
bisschen auflockern
bobby und ich haben uns bereit und wir
sind zu einem entschluss gekommen
wir klatschen bisschen wir klatschen für
alle leute die sich den lieferdienst
nach hause holen und nicht mal einen
müden cent trinkgeld geben wenn ihr euch
lieferdienste nach hause holen lässt
lasst dann gibt den trinkgeld nur damit
ihr versteht was für boxfan ich bin
anhänger klatsch koffer beginne eine
runde des berühmten spiels ich packe
meinen koffer
der verlierer muss klatschen ich packe
meinen koffer und packe ein knack und
back brötchen und bernd ciena knack und
brötchen börsianer seifenblasen und
ainring licht eindringlich versuchen
thema aus dem beginn einer aufzählung
haushaltsgeräte wie waschmaschine
maschine kitchenaid der automat julia
kaffeemaschine wasserkocher
ich finde der hintergrund ist bis jetzt
ganz gut gelungen ich lass das jetzt mal
einfach so ich fasse es jetzt auch nicht
mehr an und kann mich jetzt um die
mittel frage mich ob ich gerade mich
rein man soll also vanessa oder bobby
noch mit seiner x palette vielleicht ist
das schaffe ich nicht das schaffe ich
dafür brauchen wir den leuten pinsel
jetzt kuhglocke aber abonnierte nicht
für diesen konnten weil diesem konter
dann gibt es wirklich nur einmal zu
wiederholen ich muss jetzt ein oberthema
aussuchen und dazu sagen mir dinge
youtube-kanäle julien mir relativ egal
die pferde kanäle raus
noch fehlt die außenseiter mein name ist
anders hätte lebenszeit unsympathisch tv
[Gelächter]
abonniert mal war also ein ganzen
karneval würde ich damit nicht aushalten
glaube ich aber ist auf jeden fall mein
erstes halloween oder so bob ross und
dann aber manchmal school es irgendwie
mit so einem pinsel der mir durch den
kopf geht oder so weißt du ja okay jetzt
kommen wir zur iconic wirklich iconic
her
bob ross im nebel schnick schnack
schnuck es ist ein bolzenschneider
obstsorten so lustig obstsorten wie
banane apfel wieder oranier märsche
papaya mango stärke frucht erdbeere
traube glaube wassermelone die zähne
putzen kokosnuss ist dass wir jetzt auch
sozusagen durchgespielt wird sie auch so
an ich würde sagen ich bin sogar fertig
ich weiß jetzt am ende nochmal versaut
habe ich definitiv noch mal versaut wir
uns ja so kompliziert aber es hat sehr
viel spaß gemacht dankeschön an meine
wunderbar assistenten hinter der kamera
kelly ich wünsche mir dass wir bald mal
wieder zusammen malen können und ich
würde an der stelle sagen groß ganz
schnell habe ich rote augen ich weiß
nicht erkennbar so fertig aus in dem
video aber betrunken fällt es mir
endlich mal ein
hier findet ihr eine mehrkanal dort
findet ihr meinen gaming kanal man am pc
hier könnt ihr mal wanne abonnieren
und hier gibt es eine playlist mit
tollen videos oder das letzte video
es kann auch weise keine playlist
tschüss